what are your thoughts about what's been
happening with this year with the durham
report
i wish it happened a year ago or two
years ago or several years ago
though
i think okay this is just my yeah my
speculation on this
i think that
barr
knew that there were egregious abuses
but he didn't want to do anything that
would become a 2020 campaign issue and
so he wanted to get to the bottom of
this but he was so concerned about him
him he himself looking politicized that
he didn't want to do it here's the
problem you literally wasted i should
say wasted because he got some great
things done
but that first two years of the the
trump administration how many tens of
millions of dollars how many cnn
interviews how many msnbc broadcasts and
shows
devoted purely to all the mola molar in
in russia russia russia nonsense
how much money and time and effort was
wasted into all of this
i mean even this moeller report in what
we know what started it it ultimately
you have this steele dossier which
helped to swirl up suspicion but
disproven you have all these alpha bank
allegations that were used to swirl up
suspicion now it's coming back sussman's
going to be um have a nice custom fitted
orange suit at a certain point here and
that's good he's you know probably not
going to like his time in a cell
but here's the thing i think everybody
is missing from this who gave these guys
their orders now we saw in the closing
days of 2016 we saw jake sullivan by the
way the current national security
advisor for biden in the white house
wrote a memo about these alleged trump
ties that hillary then tweeted out and
was talking about
we saw hillary bring it up just uh just
before halloween in uh in 2016 uh with
the whole trump russia uh connections or
the alleged connections
so clearly there's communication in the
clinton camp sussman was billing the
clinton campaign for his work
why is nobody saying who gave him his
orders who signed off on the approvals
what was the the chain of custody and
chain of command for reporting that
information back up
i i think the uh the rotting fish here
uh goes up i don't know if it's to the
actual head but i think it goes higher
up there so there's no way this is all
just a are you obama is that kind of
where you're going are you going you're
going hillary you're going biting you're
going obama i i don't know but but i
know that this is not uh michael sussman
did not drive this entire thing by
himself so yeah this is
going back to jake sullivan
oh but that's uh but that's i mean this
jake sullivan just make it bigger is the
national
security advisor in biden's white house
today here's crooked on uh
october 31st on halloween 2016
going to this statement uh this memo
that jake sullivan put together
and talking about the i mean where did
this magically it's not like you just
can we read it because everybody's seen
this picture let's just read it make it
a little bit a statement from uh jake
solomon on new report exposing trump's
secret line of communication to russia
in response to a new report from uh
state
showing that the trump organization has
a secret server registered to trump
tower that has been
covertly communicating with russia
hillary for uh american senior policy
adviser jake sullivan released the
following statement on monday this could
be the most direct link between donald
trump and moscow computer scientists
have apparently uncovered a covert uh
server link the trump organization to
russian-based bank
the secret hotline may be the key to
unlocking the mystery of trump's ties to
russia it
certainly seems the trump organization
felt it had something to hide given that
it apparently took steps to conceal the
link between it was discovered by
journalists this type of communication
may help explain trump's bizarre
adoration for vladimir putin endorsed of
so many pro-criminal positions
throughout his campaign it raises even
more troubling question in light of
russia's masterminding of heckling
uh hacking efforts that are clearly
intended to hurt hillary clinton's
campaign i can't read that part there
anyway so so
hitler
the next line says we can only assume
that federal authorities will now
explore this direct connection between
trump and russia again jake sullivan now
the national security adviser he was the
policy director for hillary's campaign
in 2016. national security advisor
what's going to happen to him
well that's what i'm saying that's why
jim jordan's been going after him saying
number one we got it in josh hawley has
also lit him up saying this guy we got
to make sure he doesn't have any
connection with any doj investigations
or anything that's going on because
concerned about that he might go and try
to scuttle things or try to cover it i
think i think
sullivan needs to be hauled up in front
of congress i think law enforcement
needs to talk to him
there's i wouldn't know about every
communication that sussman and sullivan
have had and that's where i don't get
maybe this is what durham's referring to
and he's just being overly coy at this
point but they need to be asking uh
sussman what exact communications was he
having with sullivan or anyone else on
the qriket's campaign so so to be fair
hillary responded yesterday when she was
walking out of a car somebody said so
what do you have any comments on durham
and she didn't say anything right but
this is what she tweeted i actually want
to read the
article from vanity fair so
hillary clinton yesterday uh
trump and fox are desperately spinning
up a fake scandal to distract from his
real ones so it's a day that ends in why
the more he misdeeds are the more his
mysteries are exposed the more they lie
for those interested in reality here's a
good debunking of the latest response
okay go up a little bit before you click
on that
go go up a little bit i won't see how
many likes it got okay
for a tweet like that okay how many
followers does hillary have go click on
her profile just to see him just click
yeah
31 million followers okay go go up a
little bit to show the tweet
go up a little bit to show that tweet
that she had up okay maybe then just
okay there you go
for somebody have 30 million followers
for only 30 000 people to like your post
the biggest name that really said
anything positive to defend her with
keith oberman which keith oberman hasn't
had credibility for a long time but
click on vanity fair click on fan vanity
fair let's read the article
uh let's read this our gold it's not a
long article by the way okay so let's
see who wrote it go find out who wrote
it who wrote it what's her name
best levin
do we know who best 11 is
no but i like that uh hillary had to
revert to vanity fair to uh well we know
we
let me read the article go a little
lower i mean the headline what was the
headline yeah unless breaking of the
headlines you'll never believe it but
hillary did not in fact spy on trump's
white house okay cool let's read it
uh go lower let's read it all right so
make it a little bit bigger so i can see
it from here
imagine if you will that a special
counsel appointed by the federal
government declared in a court filing
that he had evidence that a major
political figure
let's call her hillary clinton had paid
spies to infiltrate the white house and
run surveillance on donald trump in
order to frame
him as a foreign asset the whole thing
would be a big flipping deal one for
which there would be major major
consequences and far-reaching fallout
the country may uh the world would be
griped uh gripped by the story and for
reason good reason a former candidate
for office spying on the president in
the white house and that would be crazy
and you're right it would be crazy if
something like that actually had
happened which it didn't
though unfortunately for some reason
logic and the concept of the true donald
trump fox and various other deranged
conservatives cannot be convinced of
that yes as you've probably heard on
saturday the former president released a
statement claiming that special donor he
meant to say gendron but was apparently
too angry to keep his johns and his
roberts straight but has
uncovered indisputable evidence that my
campaign has presidency were spied on by
operatives paid a hillary clinton
campaign an effort to develop a
completely fabricated connection to
russia okay so far we don't have any
details just opinion a scanner for
greater in scope and magnitude than
watergate for which trump suggests that
those involved should be executed but
would settle for criminal prosecution
the problem neither john not neither
robert durham nor john durham nor anyone
else for that matter has actually
provided evidence for such crime let
alone even suggested it all right so
let's see what this says when john
durham the trump air special counsel
investigating and inquiring to russia 26
election interference father uh
pre-trial motion on friday night he
slipped in a few extra sentences that
set off a fear among right-wing outlets
about perpetrated spying on okay i don't
know entire narrative appear mostly
wrong okay there's no explanation here
the latest example began with the notion
that mr motion mr doramus falls and goes
against michael a sussman cyber security
lawyer with links to the democratic
party the prosecutor has accused mr
sussman of line during a september 26th
meeting with the fbi official about
donald trump's uh possible links with
russia the filings was uh austin how do
you pronounce that word ostensibly
ostensibly about potential conflicts of
interest but it also recounted a meeting
meeting at which mr sussman had pre
presented other suspicions to the
government and for every okay so go down
is there any more details than just to
say it's not right according to the
filing suspense had gotten information
from technology executive rod rodney
jaffe which whose company nustar had
performed server related work to the
white house and durham's estimation
jaffe and his colleagues had exploited
this arrangement by mining
for the purpose of gathering derogatory
information about donald trump fox news
took those alliance from durham's filing
and ran with it claiming durham had said
that found the clinton campaign at pay
technology company infiltrate white
house server the lack of
similarly baseless claims
from the mainstream media led trump to
declare the press refuses to even
mention the major crime that took place
this is itself a scandal the fact that
the story is so big so powerful it's
okay i got it so she's just saying in
other words
i don't think anything was there i don't
see a
detailed breakdown here's the thing
hillary didn't say anything hillary just
said that vanity fair went and disputed
it and this is another day ending and
why it's not a denial from hillary
clinton how do you read that well i
guess here's the question and to your
point
you said hey i wish this happened two
years ago
what i'm asking is
if hillary was running again in 2024 and
i obviously were speculating she could
only whatever it'd be alien i don't
think she's going anywhere right
but
then this would be a major story right
think of benghazi think of the email
think of the servers these are things
they could use against her but if she's
not running
and
you know we're talking about this robert
durham john durham report
is this a story that just kind of dies
on the vine where is it going because
there's no one to rail against hillary
hillary it's like dude we're in 2024
you're talking about 2016. where's the
relevancy here if she was still running
i could understand that why is that
important
because a lot of this uh spying happened
after the 2016 election when you talk
about trump's white house obviously that
only happens after january 20th 2017
when he's inaugurated and he takes in so
it goes even beyond the 2016 campaign
then into um
ostensibly the 2020 campaign and the
concern is with so much uh
so much going on as far as hacking or
government surveillance or monitoring i
want to know also how far did that go
did it just magically stop in say
january february of 2017 did it go
further we saw this computer firm also
worked for the uh the biden campaign i
we want to make sure this never happens
again from anybody that there's this uh
is now again the digital snooping and
spying i even have concerns even from
the government side so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]